[Musique]
voilà un monsieur qui de toute évidence
domine la situation
c'est du point de vue le plus élevé
qu'il contemple biarritz car nous sommes
ici à biarritz la preuve
mais où va-t-il sur ce qu'on peut
vraiment appeler une monture vous voulez
vous qu'ils aillent dans ce singulier
qui part sinon sinon au cirque
[Musique]
et oui bien ri vient d'être l'une des
étapes quotidiennes du grand cirque
pinder rts avec son merveilleux
spectacle est notre amie jacqueline
duforest art pays pour vous et pour nous
ces images d'une piste si familière aux
téléspectateurs et aux auditeurs
[Musique]
pas de vrai cirque sans l'effort l'homme
défaut est l'un des rares dompteur
français n'y a pas tellement vous avez
vous allez voir tout à l'heure il
s'appelle maurice schérer un soir une de
ses tantes r peut-être celle daf l'a
attaquée est littéralement déchiquetée
bilan sept mois d'hôpital pour le
dompteur et la panthère finalement donc
fait par lui
[Musique]
à de cirque eux non plus sans les clowns
ceux du cirque pinder rtf sont les rives
health
[Musique]
à
et voici le fameux numéro d antarès qui
a reçu l'oscar du cirque
non cela ne fait pas de voltige cette
charmante petite trapéziste des antarès
se nomme patricia elle a 15 ans beaucoup
de courage et l'amitié de tous les gens
du cierge
[Musique]
ce cavalier vous le reconnaissez bien
sûr et vous l'avais déjà repéré au fil
de nos images c'est le grand sympathique
c'est roger lanzac l'animateur bien
connu comme on dit qui fit naguère ses
tout débuts dans une émission de jean
nohain à la radio et vous savez la radio
continue pour lui tous les jours et le
cirque aussi
[Musique]
nous avons l'honneur de vous présenter
monsieur lanzac olivier sur le
dancefloor son père olivier se tiennent
beaucoup à la comptabilité et à la
technique et voici mademoiselle major
illzach fille du même et soeurs du
précédent car les enfants de roger
lanzac le suivent dans sa grande tournée
d'été sous le chapiteau ils ont bien de
la chance
les enfants de ranger leurs
[Musique]
n'est ce pas mesdames n'est ce pas mme
loiselle la représentation est
maintenant finie mais le grand voyage
continue
[Musique]
oui le grand voyage continuer comme ça
qu soir il faut démonter le cirque pour
le replanter ailleurs ou d'autres
d'estivants qui sont aussi des auditeurs
et des téléspectateurs retrouveront
grandeur nature en relief et en couleurs
leur chair piste aux étoiles
[Musique]